للمزيد من التفاصيل معنا الان من رفح
مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام ارحب بك كيف
تبدو الاجواء هذا
الصباح اجواء صعبه ودام لا سيما مع
استمرار الغارات الاسرائيليه على اكثر من
منطقه غارات اسرائيليه وايضا قصف مدفعي
عنيف يستهدف ربما كافه محافظات وسط وجنوب
قطاع غزه البدايه من من جنوب قطاع غزه حيث
خانيونس حيث استه فت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه مجموعه من المواطنين ونقل الى
مستشفى ناصر ثلاثه شهداء وخمس اصابات من
جراء استهداف هؤلاء المواطنين في منطقه
العرايشه في غرب مدينه خانيونس هذه هي
غارات متفرقه تشنها طائرات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما بين فين واخرى على كافه
محافظات غزه تستهدف في جلها مواطنين
ومنازل مدنيه فلسطينيه وبالتالي ينقل عداد
من الشهداء والجرحى الى مستشفيات القطاع
المختلفه في خانيونس كان القصف عنيفا
واستهدف ايضا منازل ز المدنيه فلسطينيه
منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى او منذ ساعات
الفجر والطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه تنفذ
غارات سواء في خانيونس او حتى في رفح في
جنوب القطاع حيث استهدفت فقط في رفح
لوحدها خمسه منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ونقل
عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى وجل ه هؤلاء
الشهداء والجرحى هم من النازحين الذين
هربوا من القصف الاسرائيلي في مناطق
مختلفه من مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع
والمنطقه الوسطى الى رفح التي قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي للسكان ان توجهوا الى
وبعد ذلك يقصف الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى ان
بعض من هذه المنازل او منزل واحد على
الاقل هو في المنطقه الامنه الانسانيه
التي يتحدث عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي لكن
الجيش يعود ليقص هذه المنازل وفيها وفي كل
منزل ما لا يقل عن 50 فرد من افراد
العائلات الفلسطينيه يتواجدون في منزل
واحد كل منازل مدينه رفح باتت مكتظه عن
بكره ابيها لا يوجد متسع ولا لقدم واحده
عشرات بل الاف من الخيام منتشره في كاف
كافه المناطق في الشوارع في المساحات في
المساحات وفي الاراضي الزراعيه وبالتالي
اي قصف اسرائيلي ينتج عنه عشرات من
الشهداء والجرحى وبالتاكيد هناك عشرات من
المفقودين لان طواقم الاسعاف وطواقم
الدفاع المدني لا تتمكن من التوجه الى تلك
المناطق وانتشال الجثامين بسبب الازدحام
وايضا بسبب كميات الركام لا سما وان بعض
هذه المنازل هو مكون من الباطون وبالتالي
هناك اعداد من الشهداء ما تزال تحت
الانقاض في وسط ال القطاع كافه المناطق
والمخيمات في وسط القطاع باتت تتعرض وربما
يمكن وصف المشهد هناك بانه الاكثر عنفا في
ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي من مدفعيه من
مدفعيه الاحتلال وايضا من الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه منازل تستهدف منزل
لوحده لعائله تمراز في دير البلح وسط
القطاع كان هناك عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى
وما زالت طواقم الدفاع المدني تعمل على
انتشال المزيد من هذه من هؤلاء المفقودين
الذين ما زالوا تحت تت الانقاض ايضا القصف
المدفعي لا يتوقف ولا لثانيه واحده في
مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج ومخيم النصيرات
منطقه الزوايده وكل هذه المناطق باتت
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه بالاضافه ايضا الى ان طائرات
مسيره منتشره بكثافه في كافه المحافظات
وتطلق النار على على المواطنين سيده
استشهدت في خانيونس هناك عشرات من
المصابين في وسط القطاع في منطقه الزوايده
وايضا في مخيم المغاز في مخيم البريج وكل
هذه المناطق الطائرات المسيره تحلق فيها
على مدار الساعه تطلق النار على المواطنين
بالاضافه الى اعتلاء القناصه الى المباني
المرتفعه في مخيم المغازي على اطراف مخيم
المغازي عند المدخل الاساسي لهذا المخيم
على شارع صلاح الدين يتواجد هناك قناصه
اسرائيليون يعتلون مبنى وعماره سكنيه هناك
ويطلقون النار على كل من يحاول قطع شارع
صلاح الدين باتجاه مستشفى الاقصى او حتى
الخروج من مخيم المغازي باتجاه دير البل
التي طلب الجيش الاسرائيلي من السكان ان
توجهوا اليها باعتبار انها امنه لكنه حتى
النازحون الذين يحاولون الخروج من مخيم
المغازي على وجه الخصوص لا سما وان هناك
ما زال الالاف من السكان يتواجدون في هذا
المخيم هذا المخيم الصغير الذي كان مكتظا
بالسكان الذي يؤوي العشرات من النازحين في
مدارس الانرو الان يحاولون الخروج من هذا
المخيم لكنهم يجابهون باطلاق نار من قبل
القناصه ومن قبل الطائرات المسيره
وبالتالي هناك عمليات قصف مستمره ايضا على
هذه المناطق وطالت ايضا مركزا للواء في
مخيم المغازي تابع لوكاله غوث وتشغيل
اللاجئين الانرو ولا تستطيع حتى سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول الى تلك المناطق مخيم
المغازي بات محاصرا بفعل استمرار اطلاق
النار واستمرار القذائف مخيم البريج منذ
عده ايام وسيارات الاسعاف تحاول الدخول
الى هذا المخيم بعدما ابلغوا من شهود عيان
بان هناك عشرات من الشهداء والجرحى كانوا
كانوا جرحى لكن بكل تاكيد همم استشهدوا من
جراء استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي ومنع
سيارات الاسعاف من الوصول اليه هشام زقوط
من رفح شكرا جزيلا لك